nous avons trouvé des têtes de poisson
coupés abandonnés ou les têtes d'un
gosse abandonné là-bas j'ai appris à
connaître la cruauté de la ndrangheta
à travers les morts tués le long de la
les routes sont une mafia qui marche bien
partie de la chose publique la mafia qui
au sein de l'administration publique qui
à l'intérieur de la politique
J'ai eu quelques autres conceptions, mais laissez cela
ils regardent tourner la pierre de l'humeur du crime
lohan d'âge je suis un outil répété
le char a roulé sur le voisin
pulpe fermée
[Musique]
d'accord
Nous voilà
le premier quand j'ai gagné les concours j'étais
mis en danger par les taureaux et ainsi je pourrais
passer un bon moment à aller travailler dans le nord
une grande ville où j'ai préféré rester
en Calabre pour tenter de contrer
la mafia donc nicola gratteri je suis né
ici en calabre une ville de la province de
la calabre en 58 intéresse particulièrement
d'enquêtes contre les ndrangheta e
contre le trafic de drogue et la relation
mafia politique
à partir de 86 que je vis sous escorte et puis
elle est prête à tout
sacrifice n'allez pas à la mer pas dans
vélo ne pas faire de moto ne pas y aller
pour avoir une glace il faut toujours rester
enfermé dans la maison ou dans la voiture a
blindé au bureau
[Des rires]
[Musique]
les origines ndrangheta depuis linda prima
l'unité de l'Italie
dans cette société
les picciotti qui ont fait des raids
ils vivaient en volant
ou des animaux ou en imposant le harcèlement
aux paysans
puis peu à peu il a grandi jusqu'à
se structurer dans une action criminelle et la
structure de base la ndrangheta et la
famille 23 familles patriarcales forment
action c'est la force de
ndrangheta le lien du sang
[Musique]
Italie chevronnée avec des systèmes dynamiques
déjà mitreski je peux bonjour les avantages
confiscation des avoirs de la mafia
c'était une chose très importante
révolutionnaires sont tels et tant de biens
saisi puis confisqué qu'il
l'état ne peut plus les gérer
mon nom est domenico fans sérieux je suis le
président de la coopérative valle del
terre libre marro et vivre dans les dirigeants
en Calabre et par la suite d'autres
d'autres attaques le feu dans les oliveraies
la coupe des vénitiens le feu de
signifie que nous avons calculé en moyenne que dans
ces années en moyenne tous les six mois
nous avons subi une attaque
même des menaces personnelles avec des signaux
clairement nous avons trouvé des têtes de
poissons coupés abandonnés ou les têtes de
un gosse abandonné là du tout à
porte d'entrée d'un terrain e
donc tous les signes clairs que
ils avaient ça comme but
décourager cette initiative
l'histoire de domenico l'histoire de
garçons de la vallée de la mer est un
très belle histoire est une histoire de
enfants qui ont grandi dans
paroisse
je suis don pino de masi je suis prêtre
Je dis toujours que si je les ai élevés oui
ils ont grandi avec une main de la mer
l'évangile et la constitution dans l'autre
républicain et ils l'ont déjà fait
des choix courageux
dès le plus jeune âge
donc il nous a fait comprendre que pour ça
ce n'est pas une vie que nous ne méritions pas
pour que ce soit nous les
les protagonistes ne pouvaient pas être là
ndrangheta notre protagoniste
la vie
beaucoup le disent administrations
les municipalités n'ont jamais voulu donner
leur contribution parce qu'il est clair qu'il y a
collusion avec blessure avec eux
familles mafieuses
on sait que sur 33 communes de la plaine de
joie tauro et environ 60 70 pour cent
au moins une des municipalités a été dissoute
le temps des infiltrations mafieuses
[Musique]
plus une mafia de ravisseurs
personne n'est plus la mafia de
trafiquants de cocaïne mais une mafia qui
gère une grande partie des affaires publiques
la mafia dans le public
l'administration qu'au sein de la politique
la mafia et la laideur n'est pas la beauté
nous devons faire un environnement plus beau
mais où l'environnement est signifié
tout d'abord aux gens partout dans le monde
créé en confisquant des actifs en réalité
il enlève non seulement l'argent de la mafia
pouvoir mais aussi consentement en plus de
fournir de l'argent et du pouvoir leur a fourni
consentement parce que les gens sont allés à
leur demander quelque chose et puis oui
ils étaient addictifs
en 2006 puis après deux ans que
nous avons mis nettoyé et récupéré et
ces terres viennent le premier est le
première véritable attaque
nous étions prêts à cueillir les olives
dans les jours précédents, ils se sont présentés
des personnes sur le terrain était l'invitation
qu'ils nous avaient fait aller
prendre un café chez eux ou un café
nous ne l'avons jamais bu
jamais allé
et ils les ont mis dans
réservoirs de nos tracteurs
du ramasseur de réservoir d'huile
et du sucre était un geste
symbolique pour eux de nous faire comprendre que
c'était la conséquence d'avoir
refusé ce café ayant refusé cela
compromis en ce qui me concerne
ce moment je bois le café amer
je n'utilise plus je ne mets plus de sucre c'est à dire
le café amer représente cela pour moi
je dois toujours garder à l'esprit que non
il ne faut jamais faire de compromis
juste pour les ouvrir mais ils les aident
à la lutte contre la mafia et donc il faut
aider dans ces associations
coopératives
tu dois rester près de moi pour me protéger
parce que ce sont des choses sérieuses et concrètes
c'est le vrai anti-mafia
nous n'avons toujours pas vaincu
ndrangheta nous avons vaincu la peur là-bas
la peur chez les jeunes et la peur aussi chez
beaucoup de familles n'ont pas moins de jeunes
plus de peur
et puis aussi les menaces de quiconque
type que moi aussi j'ai eu été surmonté